[Music]
good morning John it's Friday June 1st
are not time for it to be June yet I was
made so short
stupid May my life is slipping away tic
toc tic toc tic toc tic toc slipping
through my fingers what I mean to say is
that life's too short for brothers to be
angry at each other which is why you're
just going to have to adventure wrong
your response to my derision of Barack
Obama was maybe a little bit
unconvincing I said that he was
well-spoken and attractive to that list
you added smart um
I think that we might have to admit the
Brotherhood 2.0 is not going to be able
to endorse a candidate in the 2008
elections because we might not be voting
for the same person
I mean I'll vote for Barack Obama if
he's running against Mitt Romney but I
might not vote for Barack Obama if he's
running against John McCain this country
has a lot of problems and Barack Obama
has a lot of good ideas but you can't
sit there and tell me that a candidate
is smart if he wants to increase the
amount of carbon dioxide that our
automobile fleet produces by over 100
percent that's not smart
that's uh that's stupid liquid coal is
an extremely bad idea it's the exact
opposite of everything I work for while
I recognize that there are a lot of
issues that are important to me and that
maybe should even be more important to
me than global warming this is what I do
it's what I care about the most it's
what I spend all of my time doing and I
just can't support someone who is not
only a supporter but like the
congressional champion on the Democratic
side I like it when he talks it makes me
happy when Hillary Clinton talks it
makes me nauseous but that is not a
reason to vote for a candidate obviously
what's worse is that there are so many
cars in America we don't need them all
frankly I think that I need one less
that was me yesterday putting my money
where my mouth is John you may already
be angry at me but I might be about to
make you more angry at me I'll let
yesterday self tell you about that so
you can be angry at him instead of me
Catherine and I have become a one-car
family and there's a certain advantage
to becoming a one-car family 90 of these
that's two this is 88 oh we have sold
the less fuel-efficient of the two cars
also the much more expensive of the two
cars a very intentionally videotaped
this yesterday so that no one would know
that I have this much money until I put
it in the bank which I'm about to go do
so don't come over and try to rob me
because I've already deposited it this
kind of scares the crap out of me same
time I just kind of want a rover on
myself oh it's hard to be down on losing
a really nice car when you've got your
handful of eighty eight hundred dollar
bills
I mean ninety ninety hundred dollar
so maybe I'm just gonna invest it all in
solar stocks I have faith in the solar
power industry man that guy is such a
jerk he totally sold the sob you love
the sob I don't believe he did that make
sure that he knows he's done you wrong
but I'm on your side
I'm all behind you on all the different
reasons why you're angry we should be
friends
thank you for challenging me to make a
forum I'm working on it
and I challenge you to move to
Indianapolis because right now I don't
think you need anything else on your
plate done I'll see you on Monday